[Música]
según los resultados preliminares del
izquierdista gustavo petro resultó el
gran ganador de la primera vuelta en las
elecciones presidenciales colombianas
pero la sorpresa la dio el populista
rodolfo hernández quien se quedó con el
segundo puesto ambos candidatos se
enfrentarán en la segunda vuelta el 19
de junio
el gran derrotado en las elecciones
colombianas es el establecimiento
gustavo petro de izquierda y rodolfo
hernández populista de derechas son
percibidos como candidatos anti
establecimiento y el perdedor federico
gutiérrez quien era favorito para pasar
la segunda vuelta tenía el respaldo del
gobierno y los partidos tradicionales
la ofensiva rusa continúa su avance en
el donbass donde las tropas de vladimir
putin han destruido todas las
infraestructuras importantes de la
ciudad de cebr odón y es el principal
objetivo militar de moscú para tomar el
control completo de la región de luhansk
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en colombia con el
99,99 por ciento de las mesas informadas
en el preconteo que hace la
registraduría nacional la dupla de
izquierda de gustavo petro y francia-
márquez lidera con un 40 a 32 por ciento
de los votos seguida de la populista de
derecha a rodolfo hernández y su
compañera de fórmula marilyn castillo
con 28 a 15 por ciento él hasta hace
poco favorito para pasar a segunda
vuelta federico gutiérrez de derecha y
apoyado por todos los partidos
tradicionales quedó en tercer lugar con
menos del 24 por ciento y en un distante
cuarto lugar con
4.2 por ciento se hundió el candidato
del centro sergio fajardo
y así recibió su triunfo con el 43% de
los votos gustavo petro quien hizo el
discurso más largo de los candidatos que
hablaron al conocerse los resultados
llamo a conseguir el millón de votos que
a su juicio necesita para ganar en
segunda vuelta
nosotros queremos un cambio que
construye aquí paz
que acabe la violencia porque lo que
buscamos es una colombia potencia
mundial de la vida así que
estamos a un millón de votos de ganar
un millón de votos más
de estos 8 millones y medio de lectores
si esta cifra cambia el 8 por un 9
ganamos el candidato populista de
derecha rodolfo hernández confirmó lo
que anunciaban las encuestas en las
últimas semanas que lo mostraban con un
crecimiento sostenido se llevó a cerca
del 28 por ciento de los votos se
pronunció a través de una red social
con la votación que obtuvo mi propuesta
de gobierno hoy gana una ración del
trabajo hoy ganas ganó la nación de la
honestidad hoy ganó el país que no
quiere seguir ni un solo día más con los
mismos y las mismas que nos han llevado
a la situación dolorosa en que hoy
estamos ahora entramos al segundo tiempo
y estos próximos días serán decisivos
para determinar el futuro del país soy
consciente de la necesidad de unir
nuestro país en el camino de cambio que
hoy se ha hecho evidente
contundentemente
y soy consciente de las dificultades que
vendrán cuando asuma la presidencia de
la república gustavo petro un ex
guerrillero del m-19 y ex alcalde de
bogotá intenta por tercera vez llegar a
la presidencia de colombia de lograrlo
se convertiría en el primer presidente
de izquierda en la historia democrática
de esta nación suramericana su figura
despierta temores pero también grandes
esperanzas entre los millones de
colombianos que desean un cambio en el
rumbo del país a continuación los
invitamos a conocer en detalle el
historial del candidato del pacto
histórico
es la apuesta más popular de la
autodenominada izquierda progresista y
el personaje más mediático gustavo petro
originario del departamento de córdoba
creció y se inició como sindicalista
durante su adolescencia en zipaquirá a
los 17 años se hizo un militante de la
guerrilla m-19 conocido como el
comandante aureliano por la novela 100
años de soledad no dejó las armas y
firmó la paz hasta 1990 momento desde el
que la defiende como parte de su
programa político
metido en política desde que salió de la
guerrilla en 2006 fue elegido como el
senador con la tercera votación más alta
de la historia del país en 2011 se
convirtió en el alcalde de bogotá con
más del 32 por ciento de los votos pero
su mandato terminó estrepitosamente con
una revocatoria en su contra entre otros
motivos por la gestión del sistema de
basuras de bogotá el alcalde mayor de
bogotá independientemente quien se solo
puede ser destituido por causas
taxativas
escritas en la ley por el presidente de
la república hablamos aquí en golpista
con dos intentos fracasados de conseguir
la presidencia del país en 2010 y 2018
respectivamente vitro ha mantenido su
política centrada en la lucha contra la
pobreza la desigualdad y la corrupción
en el país los colombianos no tenemos en
nuestros genes la violencia los y las
colombianas lo que no hemos sabido es
tener oportunidades y ahora con sus
políticas sociales
a favor del paro nacional del 2021 el
político representa un desafío a la
sucesión de gobiernos de derecha que han
ocupado el poder en colombia
históricamente
29 de mayo
es el grito de la libertad en colombia
porque the record de rock haremos el
régimen de corrupción porque cambiaremos
la historia porque abriremos las sendas
para que podamos convivir en paz no
obstante a pesar de su popularidad su
figura genera gran polarización entre la
sociedad colombiana
un tip toquero septuagenario apodado el
donald trump colombiano rodolfo
hernández logró hacer calar su mensaje
en contra de la corrupción a través de
una muy hábil estrategia en redes
sociales que llegó a los jóvenes ya los
ciudadanos cansados de la política
tradicional empecé a estar el mismo
llamado a juicio por acusaciones de este
tipo a continuación les presentamos el
perfil del candidato que se disparó en
las encuestas en las últimas semanas de
la contienda electoral y que hoy logró
llegar a la segunda vuelta presidencial
de colombia alva santana nos cuenta
se llama a sí mismo ingeniero rodolfo
hernández como si su profesión fuera
parte de su nombre y se autodefine como
un líder del mundo de la política
natural del departamento de santander al
noreste de colombia hernández creció en
el seno de una familia liberal y
siguiendo el consejo de su abuela
trabaje con los pobres y se hará rico
consiguió amasar una fortuna en el mundo
de la construcción como ingeniero civil
y empresario a pesar de que ya había
estado en política desde mucho antes su
carrera despegó en 2015 cuando fue
elegido alcalde de la capital de
santander o bucaramanga desde entonces
sus bases políticas son las mismas lucha
contra la corrupción la que llama buena
administración del dinero público y cero
impunidad con los criminales esta
situación no da para esperar si queremos
estar mejor la única solución desea
acabar con la corrupción y también con
vencimiento de llegar hasta los más
vulnerables con un discurso y políticas
fuertemente populistas
en un compromiso que los colombianos más
pobres
tengan un mejor vivir
muchos lo definen como el donald trump
colombiano que entró en el mundo de la
política como multimillonario y se
presentó como la opción anti
establishment aunque se han probado sus
nexos con políticos tradicionales y
otras polémicas como la filtración de
sus amenazas a un cliente de su
constructora por teléfono o un entramado
de corrupción el vita logic en el que se
le acusa de conceder un contrato público
supuestamente a dedo acusaciones que
siempre ha negado presentándose incluso
como puro no otros
con puro tm
corazón muy bien
a pesar de sus 77 años hernández logra
llegar hasta sus seguidores a través de
redes sociales conocido como el viejito
rey del edicto
fácil
me conformo
desde donde pide a la población que se
suba a la rodolfo nita y vote por él y
cambiamos de tema y vamos a brasil al
menos 84 es el número de muertos en el
estado de pernambuco a raíz de las
intensas lluvias que han provocado
deslizamientos de tierra las labores de
rescate continúan ya que decenas de
personas siguen desaparecidas las
precipitaciones han venido golpeando
fuertemente al país desde inicios de
este año los detalles con nuestra
corresponsal valeria saccone
no para de subir el número de muertos en
pernambuco el estado del noroeste de
brasil afectado por fuertes lluvias a lo
largo de toda esta semana ya son 14 los
municipios que han declarado el estado
de emergencia y los bomberos siguen
buscando a personas con vida entre los
escombros porque hay de momento al menos
50 desaparecidos el estado de pernambuco
ha destinado 100 millones de reales 21
millones de dólares para obras en esas
ciudades más afectadas y el presidente
de brasil y jair bolsonaro ha anunciado
en sus redes sociales que mañana lunes
visitará recife la capital de pernambuco
para conocer de cerca la situación
también ha prometido dinero y ayuda a
las familias afectadas hay que recordar
que brasil está sufriendo mucho este año
por las lluvias torrenciales en marzo en
la ciudad de petrópolis en el estado de
río de janeiro fuertes deslizamientos
causaron 233 muertos y en enero en el
estado de bahía también en el noroeste
también por las lluvias torrenciales
hubo 27 muertos
54 mil personas tuvieron que dejar sus
casas tuvieron que ser desalojadas
algunos especialistas atribuyen esa
situación al cambio climático y de
momento la situación en pernambuco sigue
delicada porque no para de llover
pasamos ahora a ucrania las fuerzas
rusas avanzan con el objetivo de hacerse
con el control total de la región del
donbass los esfuerzos se concentran en
la ciudad de severodonezk en la
provincia de lugansk nuevo objetivo de
las tropas de moscú donde -según el
presidente- volodymyr selenski casi la
totalidad de la infraestructura crítica
ha sido destruida el informe es de
rafael pérez y javier sin curso me está
agradecido con todos los que mantienen
la línea de defensa en severodonezk y
muestran a los ocupantes que la paz era
nuestra una frase que marca la gravedad
de la situación en el este de ucrania a
decir del mandatario con el avance de
las tropas rusas la situación es
indescriptible mente difícil
ser honestos a raíz de los ataques rusos
en severo don jets toda la
infraestructura crítica de la ciudad fue
destruida el 90% de los están dañados
más de dos tercios de las viviendas
residenciales están completamente
destruidas no hay telecomunicaciones el
bombardeo es continuo pues sin coste
según autoridades ucranianas el
incremento de la ofensiva sobre
severodonezk tiene el objetivo de
capturar la región oriental de lugansk
tras retirarse del norte de ucrania
moscú enfocó una segunda fase de la
llamada operación militar especial en
tomar el control del donbass con el
apoyo de los separatistas pro rusos
intenciones que fueron reiteradas por el
ministro de asuntos exteriores ruso
serguéi lávrov la liberación de las
regiones de donges y lugar reconocidas
por rusia como estados independientes es
una prioridad incondicional
según el instituto para el estudio de la
guerra los rusos no habrían logrado
rodear esta estratégica urbe separado ni
ski lysychansk son las últimas zonas
importantes bajo el control ucraniano en
la provincia de lugansk por lo que se
teme que esta zona pueda convertirse en
una nueva mariupol y por primera vez
desde que inició la guerra en ucrania el
presidente del país volodymyr selenski
salió de la región capital y visitó a
jarque la segunda ciudad más importante
allí despidió al jefe de servicio de
seguridad regional por no protegerla en
los primeros días del conflicto después
del viaje del mandatario se escucharon
varias explosiones en la urbe con pablo
loco - cuenta más
es la primera vez que el presidente
ucraniano visita una de las zonas más
golpeadas por la guerra volodymyr
selenski llegó este domingo a jarque
para discutir la posibilidad de
reconstruir nuevas viviendas en la
azotada zona del este del territorio
ucraniano según el gobernador cerca del
30% de la segunda región del país está
bajo posesión rusa y más de 2.100
bloques de apartamentos han sido
destruidos por las tropas de moscú
tenemos que encontrar dinero y líneas de
crédito porque las ciudades los
gobernadores y los alcaldes tienen más
posibilidades de encontrar uno u otro
programa europeo para la construcción de
viviendas algunos programas estatales y
otros locales como su primera salida de
la capital desde la invasión rusa el 24
de febrero se leen que también visitó a
las tropas desplegadas en el frente de
batalla las felicito y les mostró su
apoyo
previamente el mandatario pidió a eeuu y
a sus socios europeos más apoyo en
tecnología antiaérea para lograr hacerle
frente a la ofensiva rusa que ha
enfocado sus esfuerzos en el donbass de
una y otra vez recordarle al mundo que
rusia debe ser finalmente reconocida
oficialmente como un estado terrorista y
un estado patrocinador del terrorismo
esto es simplemente cierto es honesto y
refleja la realidad cotidiana que los
ocupantes han creado en ucrania y están
deseando llevar a europa mientras que el
gobierno ucraniano anunció su victoria
ante la ofensiva rusa en severodonezk un
sector clave en la región de lugansk el
ejército ruso se jactó de tener el
control sobre el imán una ciudad del
este de ucrania cuyo control abre la
puerta sobre el dominio del donbass
hasta aquí este informativo gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]